[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to this course of advanced
mechanics of solids
in this course we'll be mostly talking
about beams and plates
uh will not be restricted to just uh the
simple deformation of beams and plates
rather we'll also be interested in the
kinds of deformations which are induced
to elastic instabilities and the way
that we are going to proceed
uh to address these various kinds of
deformations is through
a very mathematical way uh
a very general mathematical wave which
is referred to as the calculus of
variations
and which is which as you can see on the
screen is the first chapter that we are
going to
address now i want to think of this
chapter
much in the same way that we had
addressed the first
chapter in our previous course of
applied elasticity which was
mathematical preliminaries so this first
chapter of calculus of variations here
is like the mathematical preliminaries
of advanced mechanics of solids
however comparing with that earlier
course
where you had some notion of uh tensors
vectors
and things like that uh in applied
elasticity
here uh i'm sure some of you have not
even heard of this phrase calculus of
variations
so uh it's a it's a doubly dangerous
kind of situation
so neither do you know the definition of
this phrase and here i am asking you to
be motivated to
study this so so what what's the way out
so what i'll do is i'll first briefly
tell you the motivation
of this calculus of variations thinking
about it just like a method which has to
which is very useful
uh so you think of it is some method
called calculus or variations it could
be any other name
uh and then uh what is the motivation
for this
uh in terms of things which you are
already very familiar with
governing equations boundary conditions
and then once we have that motivation in
hand
we'll try to understand uh what this
calculus of variations
is about now as we had done previously
in applied elasticity when we were
talking about mathematical preliminaries
we did not take a too formal approach in
a similar fashion here also we are not
going to take
too formal an approach in fact it is
going to be utterly
and completely informal mathematically
speaking
uh rather we are going to take up a very
utilitarian kind of approach
meaning that whatever we need that only
we will
try to learn okay so
uh this is certainly not a maths course
very much a course in mechanical
engineering
uh so uh we wish to proceed accordingly
okay so first of all what is the
motivation for studying this calculus of
uh variations why why this particular
method what what benefit does it
affect us so uh
uh i could write this down but uh
i think i it will be just faster if i
quickly uh if i quickly
tell you the points which is that uh
first of all
uh if you if you just accept the fact
that calculus of variations is
some method some mathematical method
then this provides us with some sort of
an algorithmic approach
towards getting the or obtaining
the the governing differential equations
of
various mechanical systems various
mechanical systems
relevant to the context of advanced
mechanics of solids could be beams and
plates
which we'll study throughout the
semester
but more importantly once you learn
calculus or variations
you will have to appreciate the fact
that this is not just limited to
things like mechanics of solids in fact
calculus or variations
has wide ranging applications in various
branches of physics not just mechanics
so once you learn it the the general
unified principles on which this is
based
can very well be extended to study
various kinds of topics in physics
starting from electrostatics optics and
so on and so forth okay so it's it's
a it's a really worthwhile pursuit
uh next uh
through this use of calculus of
variations you will see
that not only the governing equations
come out in a systematic fashion but
together with the governing equations
almost magically and automatically the
boundary conditions also emerge
okay so in certain situations it may be
quite difficult
to uh to arrive or to guess
as we have been doing till now uh the
boundary conditions
but through this method of calculus of
variations will be able to
follow a very very systematic unified
way
of arriving at the boundary conditions
in fact for certain
instances you will realize once we do
them that
if you had not proceeded by the method
of calculus of variations
there is no way you could have arrived
at the correct set of boundary
conditions
it is that useful okay and finally
a slightly more philosophical point is
that
the calculus of variations it has a very
natural connection
with things like finite element methods
which some of you have already learned
in the previous semester uh
so so if you study advanced mechanics of
solids
things about beams and plates using
calculus of variations
then it provides us a a natural
link towards proceeding to numerical
solutions of problems
okay so this is the background
motivation now with this motivation in
place
i think it's uh it's no longer wise to
delay
uh talking about what this method is all
about and as i said
we are not going to take a very formal
mathematical approach rather it's a very
utilitarian kind of approach
to learn what we need to learn all right
so
let me just switch off this video here
and then
let's get down to the business end of
things so
to understand the calculus of variations
we are not going to directly launch into
what this definition is and so on and so
forth
rather we'll start with something which
is very very familiar to us from
differential calculus
okay so free your mind completely and
just think of
of a very simple kind of situation that
we have this kind of a
we have suppose a function like this
y is equal to 3x square so this is
something that i have arbitrarily picked
up it could be something else
okay uh where this x is lying between
uh certain in a certain domain
okay so this close domain x1 x2
this x is lying between that okay so all
of you know how to find
out uh if i ask you find out the the
minimum value of this y
within this domain all of you can find
this out okay you
you differentiate this once with respect
to x set it equal to zero find out the
extreme points
then find out the second derivative uh
uh
set that to be fine fine for what value
that is greater than zero
uh for the extreme points and then you
can say that
okay for those points for which the
second derivative is
greater than zero uh you get the minimum
all right so far so good for
differential calculus
next uh consider this integration
okay so i am presenting things to you
almost
disparately but you will soon realize
what's the connection
okay so consider this integration i
is equal to some
integration of some f of x with respect
to x
within the limits x 1 and x 2. now when
we learned integra
integral calculus uh our primary concern
was to
find out i mean uh to learn ways to find
out this integration
uh when we could not find it we we went
for numerical methods
uh maybe some to some numerical uh
techniques that you learned in your
undergraduate days
but that was the whole idea that given a
certain integrand
given certain limits you find out the
value of this integration
okay all of you are familiar with that
okay
now i want to change the nature of the
question that we want to ask
with regards to this integral uh in with
with regards to this integration
so what what i want to say is that okay
if we are given a certain f of x we know
various methods of finding
this integration we can find out this
value i
but suppose i tell you
that you are kind of
free to choose this f of x
okay you are free to choose this f of x
of course there will be certain
constraints uh you would i mean
you can't take anything or everything
that you want
there will be certain uh restrictions on
the choice of this f of x
and uh like had we been presenting in a
very mathematical way would have said
that uh you are restricted to choose
uh this curve f of x uh
from a set of admissible curves where
the admissibility would be
uh would be defined through certain
conditions
okay so if you are more mathematically
inclined probably that
that last sentence i spoke would have
would make more sense to you
anyway so what what we what we are
really interested in
getting at here is that if we change if
we if we take different different
uh values or different choices of this f
of x
certainly this integration value is
going to change
so for example if it if we substitute
this 3x squared itself here
this is going to give us a certain value
of i if we take
a sine x or a cos x or some complicated
expression that is going to give us
certainly different values of
i now question is
from among those admissible
curves f of x like among those
among those choices that we're allowed
to make uh
what is that choice which is going to
give us
a minimum value of this i you see what i
have done here
earlier this was a simple curve
and we were interested in finding out
the the minimum value of y at a certain
point x but now we are changing the
question in with regards to this
integration
what we are saying is that what is the
choice of f of x
okay we are talking about the choice of
the curve now not about any specific
point
and we are asking what or what choice of
that f of x
it is we are going to get a minimum
value of i so this is a very interesting
question
now interesting is one thing question is
where exactly do we do you need this and
what at all is the connection with
advanced mechanics of solids so we are
going to proceed towards that step by
step
so first of all forget about advanced
mechanics of solids for the time being
uh for just just uh try to see a couple
of examples
where such a question okay such a such a
interesting kind of question has some
utility
so first of all you see uh let's take
this example
that try to find a curve
okay try to find a curve find a curve
between two points
such that
the length of the curve is minimum
okay now if you just think about it for
a couple of seconds you'll realize that
what you're basically
asking is that uh if if basically a
proof
of the fact that if you join two points
by a straight line
uh it is going to give you the minimum
value but but how do you arrive at that
mathematically okay so that is that is
one this is the
as the simplest possible question you
could ask in the context
of this kind of questions okay
next so so how do we how do we uh really
express this so suppose you have a curve
a general curve y is equal to f
of x and we want to represent the length
of that curve between two points
so that length will be given by this
expression
let me write it down and you'll be able
to figure out what exactly is going on
here
okay so you think of it like this that
suppose this is our
x and this is our y
and we have this one
this is our
x1 and let's say this is
somewhere this is x2
so of course you know that
the curve which is going to give us the
minimum distance
joining these two points is going to be
a straight line but suppose you did not
know this
and you took different choices of this
curve like this
okay so what we are saying here is that
if you take
a little infinitesimal segment over this
the length of that is given by this
square root of dx
square plus dy square so think of it
like this
so this is this is that part we are
zooming in here
so this is that part so this is
the dx and this is our d
y so this length approximated
by a straight segment that is square
root of d x
square plus d y square and if we
integrate between the limits
we get the total length from here to
here
okay so our objective here is to
minimize this
capital l okay and we can rewrite this
this expression in a certain fashion so
we can write it like this
okay or uh
this d y d x from now on we will just
write it like y
dash so
[Music]
this l is equal to integration x 1 to x
2
square root of 1 plus y dash square
integrated with respect to dx so that
thing we are we have to minimize
okay right now we are not going to
launch into
the actual procedure of minimizing it
but we have just
formulated the problem another example
so in this new page let me just discuss
that
another example so
[Music]
now consider a
a frictionless uh
kind of path between two points
and imagine that you have
a little particle
moving down that part okay so let me
just
picture really depict it suppose you
have a path like this
okay some arbitrary shape and
this is frictionless and
uh some
so we have maybe
we are considering this kind of a ball
which is just moving down this path
uh you some some people uh try to
or present this problem like this is
like a
wire a frictionless wire and there is a
bead here
a little bead which is moving down this
wire i mean you can think of it in
various ways
uh doesn't matter because this is
frictionless
so the question is what is the shape of
this path
between these these two points uh such
that
when this bead or this particle is
moving down this path
it is under the action of gravity mind
you
then what is the what is the shape of
this path
which will minimize the time of travel
okay so let me
restate that question again find the
shape of this path of this
frictionless path such that a particle
moving down this path under the action
of gravity
uh it covers this this entire path
in the minimum time okay now this is a
very famous problem in the entire
history of calculus of variations
and mechanics in general uh
so so had we been doing uh
a an entire course on calculus of
variations would have could have gone
into the history of all that
uh it is the famous breckish stockholm
problem
uh and there are various youtubes videos
on this
uh you can try to take a look on that
uh so
so the problem is like this that
find the shape of the
frictionless path
such that
the particle traveling down it
on the action of gravity
sorry about that under the action of
gravity
takes the minimum time
to cover the path
so all this is fine how do we express it
in in terms of an integration so
note that we are interested in finding
out the minimum time
so let us set up our integration in the
form of a time
so uh
think of it like this that we have a
distance
and we have a certain speed uh
so we have already seen how we write the
distance
we're going to utilize that
and then the speed okay but this speed
of course will be dependent
at which position of the path we are in
uh and
of course cover this entire path
so note that this v
will be equal to square root of twice g
y okay
so if you're not sure how this came
about what you can do is you can just
do a conservation of energy like kinetic
energy is equal to potential energy
from that you can find this out you have
learned all of this in high school
physics so i'm not going to go into the
details of it
all right so if you replace this here
uh you'll see that
[Music]
this can again be written like y dash
squared
i see why this entire thing is under
square root
and this thing here is a dx okay so
so t is equal to this entire thing uh
we have to find out uh we have to find
uh the minimum t okay and again we are
not going to
go into the the exact method which we
use to find out this
minimum team rather as i said
this setup we are going to use as
motivation for
studying the calculus of variations okay
okay now if you look at uh
if you look at this previous example
here where we are talking about the
length
of the curve between two points
this l is dependent directly on the
first derivative of the curve under
consideration
okay next
so so if you think of it like a general
integration
this integration is dependent
on what it is some function of the
y dash next you see
here what are the things involved
in this i so if you think of this t like
a general integration
it is dependent on y
as well as y dash so previously it was
just
it was just y dash now it is both y and
y dash
okay so this gives us a motivation
of thinking about a very general i
okay so when we when you talk about
these kinds of
minimization problems uh
what could happen is that this i this
general integrations whether it is
length
time or any other thing which we are
trying to minimize
that could depend as we have already
seen on y
y dash it could also depend directly on
x we have not seen an example involving
that but
it could be there
and there could be higher order
derivatives involved also
okay it could be even higher order
derivatives involved so this is a very
general way
now we have been talking about
minimization now there is nothing so
sacrosanct about minimization it could
very well be
maximization okay so maybe maximize a
certain area or maximize a certain
volume
that could also be a question so
what we are really interested in here is
extremization
okay could be minimization could be
maximization
but we are more generally we are
interested in extremization of this i
and because we are interested into uh in
going
like as we go forward in taking some
concrete steps
to demonstrate what is going on and what
should be done uh instead of taking this
very general kind of dependence on
various higher order derivatives it will
be useful
if we just restrict ourselves to x y and
y
dash the principles remain the same you
can extend the theory
to higher order derivatives but to see
clearly as i have told you earlier we
are going to take a utilitarian kind of
approach
uh what we are going to do is uh will
restrict ourselves
restrict to
this kind of a situation okay
with the understanding with the implicit
understanding that the theory that we
develop
and the understanding that we gain from
that can very well be extended
to uh to integrations involving higher
order derivatives also
all right now uh
and and again i emphasize that uh we are
not
uh we are not restricted to minimization
problems
it could very well be maximization
problems also so in general
extremization of i okay
now whenever we think of this kind of
extremization
because we are so very familiar with our
notions of differential calculus
uh and we are saying that uh time and
again we are saying that
the way that we go about uh searching
for this minimum value or the maximum
value of i
is by changing or by taking different
choices of y
because note this y is the curve of
concern here
okay so back when we
we did this back when we were talking
about
this first very familiar example y is
equal to 3x square and i asked you that
you find out the minimum value of this y
of course you are going to do d y d x
okay
so much in the same way our initial
temptation
when we are talking about the
minimization or the maximization more
generally the extremization of i
with respect to different choices of y
the temptation
the initial temptation
okay the temptation is to do something
like this
d i d y okay
but this is wrong
can't do that okay so why can't we do
that
well there's a very subtle reason here
you take this this this first example
that we are considering
okay so we had this x here
and we had this y here and we were
considering various curves
between these two points with the
with the objective of finally arriving
at that curve
we know the answer of course that is a
straight line but we are
our our plan is that we are going to
arrive
at it at the answer systematically that
what is that curve which is joining
these two points and such that the
distance
is minimum so when we do that
we take different choices of this like
this like this
we don't know okay we take different
different choices of this
when we do that what are we doing
basically what we are doing is we are
sitting at a certain x
and here we are taking different values
of y
okay we are sitting at a certain x and
we are taking different values of y
again we are sitting at a certain x and
we are taking different values of y
okay so think of it like this
i think uh students find it useful to
think of it geometrically like this
however when you talk about d y it has a
different notion okay so d y
uh as we have already seen d y is like
this
okay so when you think of
d y between so this is our d
y that d y
is associated always
and always with a certain change in d x
so d y is
always accompanied
by dx okay you cannot have
the y changing when you are writing in
terms of this notation d
y when you are writing d y you sh
you have to understand that that d y
uh always has as its partner a change in
x also but this thing
that we are trying to do here in order
to arrive at the correct
curve which will give us our answer for
the minimum value of i
for that we are not changing x
x is constant and we are changing y
so this change in y is represented
by a different kind of differential
so this is ah
so this is like the variational kind of
our derivative
okay this delta y okay
so this delta y is
for a fixed x
this is the primary difference this
delta y is for a fixed x
this d y is always accompanied by d x
which is why i always emphasize to my
students that you must be very very
careful
in not using this kind of a notation
because some students do
do have a habit of using this because of
some bad habits
acquired at in high school of writing
partial derivatives sometimes using this
this delta has a very specific meaning
associated with a fixed
uh x okay so you should not be
arbitrarily using it you should only use
it
only when you when you mean this kind of
a variation
okay so okay so we have basically
uh through this discussion we have
learned what not to do
question is what to do okay that answer
we have not even
no not yet given so if we can't do this
kind of a d
i d y question is what what we should do
actually so right now
we don't have any answer okay and when
we don't have any answer
in a fundamental problem like this we
have to go down to the basics
okay so what is the basics basics is
what we
were discussing back in our first slide
in our first page
okay at the very top is y is equal to 3x
square
all of you know how to minimize this but
given that we are now at a critical
juncture
of exploring a different kind of
minimization or a different kind of
maximization or
in general an extreme new kind of
extremization problem
let us go down to the basics of how to
or how we arrived at the method of
finding out this extremization here
and perhaps from those lessons we'll be
able to
export the idea to
the current uh the current objective
okay so we are going to go down to the
uh to the the development of the method
which gives us the algorithm for finding
out this minimization or maximization
and then our hope is that we will be
able to export
the same kind of idea the fundamental
idea not directly the method but the
fundamental idea
in the case of this kind of a
extremization of
integrations okay and that we are going
to do
in our next in our next video lecture
so with this i end this part of the
lecture thank you very much